the second you started out working
you're in the Writers Guild you know and
you know you're part of the Union but we
don't go to union meetings we don't you
know there's no there's nothing like
that you know I want summer play on the
Writers Guild softball team but they me
like this it's not something that really
gathers and but now it now definitely
feels like we're part of a union it's
you and I know so I realize how you
normally think that you're kind of a
controlled it real life right and then
something like this year I go people
above me decide things I had much less
control over my life than I thought I
did I don't feel like I'm a coal miner
now or something like that but yeah it's
a weird feeling you believe in what
you're doing and you know it's important
but it's a it's a strange feeling to be
you know when you start out writing as a
you know where your dream of doing this
job as a kid you imagine it as like a
passion art thing I know it's something
you like you know you're going to write
the Great American Novel or so to be
standing on the street picketing it is a
business and as you grow up in the
business you understand it's a business
and when you're staying there and
there's hundreds of people marched
around and you you realize you're
reminded well that's the other thing is
yeah I've had have you had like the like
the Communist Party's come enjoy like
okay I'm gonna come is like a break
right um so sometimes you get these
fringe groups that try to coming in and
like hey you're one of us is like no no
I'm good
if we just on strike two weeks and then
it ended and whatever everyone would
kind of forget about it and certainly
the public would but now the longer it
goes it started to impact more people
and have and become more of a big deal i
think you know most people have that
their shows that they like to watch you
see this with baseball players in
football you know they go on strike and
has impacts the whole season and as a
fan you're affected in the way and it is
kind of becoming a historic baseball is
a good example i get think about the
baseball strike and baseball changed
yeah I mean you know unions when they go
and strike for a long period of time it
seems like we we have been on strike for
a long time we are going to be on strike
it seems like I mean they may air this
interview in the history channel at some
points right annex Lisa love to see what
happened I think people watching the
beginning because it's kind of
interesting to see what are you gonna do
without writers I think as it goes on
you see it's like all their kind of just
stalling yeah you know it's like you're
waiting for the other act to show up and
you're its like yeah but they're not
coming I don't think people say hey
these are much better without those
writers in the way on our side of the
business we know there are a lot of
people that are hurt by the strike aside
from writers and so you know when I see
the late-night guys back on the air I'm
happy for the cruise I should absolutely
you know there's so many people that
work in the office that right you don't
want them to be out of a job right by
the same token sometimes I'm out there
in the picket line and I think what's
gonna really make a difference if people
can I their house and actually join the
picket line and actually like you know
struck against like no new episodes I
don't know I don't know if people are
going to it seems like people will watch
sometimes I wonder if they'll just watch
what you give them the late night shows
i've been watching and they're not as
good without writers they they're the
host don't think they're and you get
without their writers and you cannot put
a value on how much writers mean to
anything right it's just a matter of
well the general public actually react
or they discussed are watching lots of
all dvds
I had a little party tonight and makeup
artist I've worked with a couple of
shows was there and she said that she
was going off to do a Doritos commercial
and she was really upset about that I
guess she's worked on everything from
Sex in the City 2 30 rock and all these
things and she you know she's like I
can't believe I'm doing it oriental but
you know I have to and most writers were
very lucky to we make when we were
working we make a good living and a lot
of the crew people live week to week
let's they get on long series they have
our time putting away money and and I do
I've heard some of them like really sort
of frustrated and worried and and I
definitely I feel for them almost as
much as I feel for I'll stand back
you